-So many of President Trump's
friends and aides
have abandoned him that the
only people left to defend him
are Stephen Miller
and Rudy Giuliani.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Things would be
a lot easier for Trump
if he still had Republicans
in Congress to protect him.
But now he has to
deal with Democrats
as they prepare to take control
of the House.
And right now Trump is fighting
with them over the budget.
Trump wants money
for his border wall,
and Nancy Pelosi has been
adamant that he won't get it.
And I'm just gonna guess,
from looking at the two of them,
that Pelosi is going to win.
I mean, look at the two of them.
He looks like he had a panic
attack in a steam room,
and she looks like
Neo from "The Matrix"
if he shopped at Talbots.
She's Tom Cruise.
He's "Risky Business."
In fact, Trump is so easy
to beat in these situations
that in last week's tense
meeting in the Oval Office,
Pelosi called the potential
government shutdown
a Trump shutdown,
and Trump was annoyed
that Pelosi
beat him to the punch.
-I think the
American people recognize
that we must keep
government open,
that a shutdown
is not worth anything
and that you should not have
a Trump shutdown.
-Oh, wait a minute.
Did you say Trump --
Oh. That's what
I'm gonna call it.
-You have your White House.
You have the Senate.
-Oh, were you?
Trump's like a guy
who gets checkmated in chess
and says,
"I was gonna say that."
And then you'd say,
"Why would you say that?
You didn't checkmate me."
Then he'd just eat
all the pieces.
After Pelosi outwitted Trump
in the Oval Office meeting,
the White House
got really desperate
and turned to a staffer
who has mostly stayed
out of the public eye lately,
and that's senior policy advisor
Stephen Miller.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Miller has been quiet
in the last few weeks,
although he occasionally lurks
in the backgrounds of photos
like the White House janitor
who's been dead for 30 years.
Yesterday, he went on
"Face the Nation"
to aggressively proclaim
that Trump would hold
the government hostage
if he doesn't get money
for his border wall.
-We are about five days from a
potential government shutdown,
and Republican leadership says
there's no plan.
What is the President's plan,
and will he shut it down
to get this $5 billion
in border-wall funding?
-We're going to do
whatever is necessary
to build the border wall,
to stop this ongoing crisis
of illegal immigration.
-And that means a shutdown?
-If it comes to it, absolutely.
This is a very fundamental
issue.
The Democrat Party
has a simple choice.
They can either choose to fight
for America's working class
or to promote
illegal immigration.
You can't do both.
-Yeah, uh-huh. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, what the hell's going on
with Stephen Miller's hair?
I mean, here he is
before that interview.
And here he is during it.
Is that a proceeding hairline?
Does Stephen Miller
get a hair hard-on
when he talks about the wall?
"Stephen, did you hear ICE
is breaking arrest records?"
"Eww!
Stephen has a hair boner!"
I mean, look at that thing.
It would have been
more believable
if he just Charlie Brown'd it.
Is that spray paint, or did he
get the inauguration crowd
tattooed on his head?
Trump was forced
to turn to Miller
because of the unprecedented
turnover in his administration.
For example, after
he announced the departure
of his current chief of staff,
John Kelly,
Trump said he would replace
Kelly with someone
who already works in the
White House, Mick Mulvaney.
And the White House said that
on top of being chief of staff,
Mulvaney would also keep
his current job
as the Director of the Office
of Management and Budget
and the head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau.
It's getting to the point
where there's only going to be
like four people left
in this administration
and they're each
going to have 30 jobs.
-"I'm pleased to announce that
I've appointed Stephen Miller
Secretary of State, Defense,
Commerce, head speech writer,
Communications Director,
and White House Babadook.
[ Laughter ]
And I have to say...
I have to say...
Stephen is so excited about it,
his hair boner
is down to his nose."
[ Laughter ]
Trump has lost Republicans
in Congress
and Republicans
in his own White House,
but, of course, the gravest
threat to his presidency so far
came from the man who was,
for years, closer to him
than almost anyone else,
and that's his former lawyer,
Michael Cohen.
In an interview with ABC,
Cohen made clear
that Trump had directed him
to break the law
and explained how he'd grown
apart from the President.
-I will tell you
that the gentleman
that is sitting now
in the Oval Office,
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue,
is not the Donald Trump that
I remember from Trump Tower.
He's a very different
individual.
-No, he's not
a different individual.
He's just in
a different location.
There's not an expression
"like a bull in a barn,"
but move it to a china shop,
and suddenly everyone's like,
"[Bleep].
Get this bull out of here!"
They're like,
"He was fine in the barn."
"This is not a [bleep] barn!"
Now, Trump, for his part...
for his part...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...has insisted that he had
nothing to do with the
hush-money payments Cohen made
to cover up Trump's affairs.
Trump has also argued that
Cohen should have known better,
an argument he repeated
in an interview with Fox News.
-Michael Cohen says that he lied
in order to protect you.
-Yeah.
-What's your response to that?
-Let me tell you.
I never directed him
to do anything wrong.
Whatever he did, he did
on his own. He's a lawyer.
A lawyer who represents a client
is supposed to do
the right thing.
That's why you pay them a lot
of money, et cetera, et cetera.
I think,
by "et cetera, et cetera,"
you mean because it's illegal.
Only Trump could
"et cetera, et cetera" the law.
He pulled an Elaine.
"I met a porn star,
went up to my room.
Yada yada yada. I'm an
unindicted co-conspirator."
Yet even in the last few days,
Trump's story on this
has changed again.
First, Trump insisted
he never heard of the payments.
Then he said they were legal.
Then he said
it was Cohen's fault.
And now his current lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, is saying...
So what if it was illegal?
Nobody died.
-Here's what Rudy Giuliani,
the President's lawyer,
said this week.
"Nobody got killed.
Nobody got robbed.
This was not a big crime,"
Giuliani told The Daily Beast.
And then he added,
"I think in two weeks
they'll start with parking
tickets that haven't been paid."
-This is ridiculous.
And they're going around
with this,
and you're talking about all
these other investigations.
I'm telling you, George,
they're going to go try
to look for
unpaid parking tickets.
-Oh, my God. Rudy managed
to out-crazy Stephen Miller.
Congrats, Rudy.
You get the hair boner.
[ Laughter ]
Even Trump's
closest friends and advisors
are getting as far away from him
as they possibly can,
and the only people
he has left to defend him
are Rudy Giuliani
and Stephen Miller,
and that's because people
are starting to realize
a fundamental truth
about working for Donald Trump.
You can keep your job or you
can keep your dignity, but...
-You can't do both.
-This has been "A Closer Look."